dès que les hommes quittaient le stade
tribales pour se constituer en est à
citer aux nations la vengeance privée
disparu au profit d'une répression
sociale l'état édictera des lois
destinées à protéger les individus et
leurs transgressions entraînera souvent
la mort dans des cas bien définis
depuis le code d'hammourabi 17 cents un
an avant le christ les moyens utilisés
par les collectivités humaines au cours
des âges pour se protéger des criminels
n'ont pas beaucoup varié souvent en
affirmant son autorité l'étape où sera
très loin son souci de préserver l'ordre
public au crime tout court
l'état ajoutera et cela depuis la plus
haute antiquité le crime de lèse majesté
et le crime politique la religion étant
le ciment de l'unité nationale l'état
sanctionnera très sévèrement toute
atteinte à la loi religieuse souvent par
la perte de la vie il y a un exemple
éclatant de condamnation à la fois
politique et religieuse celle du christ
considérés comme hérétiques par le
sanhédrin de jérusalem le christ doit
mourir mais dans la judée placé sous la
juridiction romaine le seul crime que
l'on peut imputer au christ pour
entraîner sa mort est le crime de lèse
majesté
aussi devant pilate le grand prêtre du
temple fait il accusé jésus de s'être
proclamé roi des juifs et quiconque se
fait roi se déclarent contre césar
affirme les accusateurs c'est donc un
ennemi de l'empereur que pilate fait
crucifier en europe
jusqu'au xviiie siècle l'administration
de la peine capitale
rivaliser en cruauté l'expiation était
lente horrible humiliante atrocement
douloureuse en france la suppression de
la barbarie dans les exécutions date
approximativement de la révolution
française
le 31 mai 91 un projet de suppression de
la peine de mort est refusée à
l'assemblée constituante ou robespierre
qui compte parmi les plus ardents
avocats de l'abolition déclare que la
peine de mort n'est pas la plus
réprimandes des peines est elle
multiplie les crimes beaucoup plus
qu'elle les prévient bien avant la
discussion du code pénal le 1er décembre
1789 le docteur guillotin avait
entretenu l'assemblée d'une machine
nouvelle avec laquelle il affirmait
pouvoir faire sauter la tête d'un
condamné en un clin d'oeil sans la
moindre souffrance par la suite
l'assemblée et zita entre la potence le
gard ou encore appliquée en espagne et
la décollation les deux premières peines
paraissant plus longue et cruelle
c'est finalement l'appareil suggéré par
le docteur guillotin qui fut choisi est
le 25 avril 1792 à guillotine entrer
pour la première fois en action place de
grève les exécutions avaient lieu
publiquement pour assurer la valeur
exemplaire de la peine de mort c'est en
juin 1939 devant la prison de saint
pierre à versailles
q lieu l'exécution de redman en place
publique ce fut la dernière du genre
toute une foule en majorité composé de
femmes frémissait se bousculaient autour
de la guillotine pour mieux voir mourir
le ténébreux assassin lendemain la
france frémit d'horreur devant cette
photographie et le gouvernement pris la
décision de supprimer définitivement ce
spectacle morbide
depuis les exécutions ont lieu à
l'intérieur des prisons entre 1950 et
1970 il a été procédé en france à 57
exécutions capitales dont certaines
comme celle de jacques fait ch en 1957
qui tua un gardien de la paix et qui
selon son aumônier mort et commence un
relancèrent dans la presse le des
bateaux jonathan sur la peine de mort en
1969 jean laurent olivier périssaient
sur l'échafaud dans la cour de la prison
d'amiens
il avait le 17 juin 67 étrangler et
violé une fillette de 11 ans est tué son
frère âgé de 10 ans l'exécution
d'olivier marque une date dans la peine
de mort en france
il a jusqu'à ce jour le dernier criminel
avoir été guillotinés depuis cette date
les condamnations à mort ont été
commuées en prison à vie par le
président de la république en europe
occidentale la france est avec l'espagne
le seul pays à pratiquer la peine de
mort pour les crimes de droit commun aux
usa en californie charles manson
leslie van noten et susan atkins hauteur
de l'horrible massacre de la villa
polanski viennent d'être condamnés à
mort par le tribunal de los angeles
si la sentence est exécuté les criminels
seront gazés
mais par le jeu des révisions de procès
les trois condamnés peuvent attendre
longtemps dans le terrible couloir de la
mort qui conduit à la chambre à gaz et
que karel sesma vendu célèbre par les
deux best seller qu'il écrivit dans la
tente de son exécution
une attente qui dure à 12 ans quand il
entra dans la chambre à gaz en mai 1960
malgré les innombrables pétition
réclamant sa grâce le mode encaissé mu
et l'osservatore romano dans son
éditorial écrivit la profonde émotion
suscitée par le cachet semaine exprime
la répugnance de la conscience moderne
contre l'idée de la peine de mort
l'homme est levé dans le christianisme
souhaite que les égarés puisse être
récupérée sentence irréparable
aujourd'hui aux usa une douzaine d'états
ont aboli la peine de mort certains ont
raison dollar près l'essence de la
criminalité après l'avoir aboli l'on
rétablit des crimes cependant même avec
le recul du temps reste difficilement
pardonnable eichmann qui orchestra le
plus grand génocide de l'histoire
contemporaine jugé par le tribunal de
jérusalem exécuté vingt ans après la
guerre
actuellement encore dans certains pays
du moyen-orient
la mutilation des voleurs est une
pratique courante alors qu'en suède les
criminels vivent dans de confortables
prison les châtiments sont souvent à
l'image des sociétés qui les décident en
ce domaine
la mansuétude semble être le privilège
de sociétés pacifiques qui se sentent
suffisamment saine moralement et
socialement pour juguler la criminalité
par d'autres moins